nous sommes quatrièmes casting toulon
marc tille miss martinique 2010 8 très
beau casting il ya pas mal de jeunes
filles qui se présentent
je crois que maintenant tout le monde
connaît le règlement les jeunes filles
connaissent le règlement donc
généralement à pratiquement toutes les
filles que nous avons vu il n'y a pas eu
de tatouage est pas taper des piercing
ni bon c'est c'est jouable et enlève ya
pas de problème
[Musique]
la maison
ces profils assez bien pour l'instant on
voit pas mal des candidates donc c'est
le choix final sera prête assez
difficile mais on verra bien et qu'elle
sera qui sera notre prochaine
ambassadrice